- Hey, what's up, y'all?
- Ooh, dude!
Hey, what you guys playing?
Oh, nothing.
Just a little DVD, right?
- Mm-hmm.
- What DVD?
Uh, it came for you in the mail.
It says, "To my fresh, dope son
from MC Mom."
[laughter]
- I can't wait to see it.
- Oh, no, no, no, no.
(all)
Hey, whoa!
- Hey, hey, hey, hey.
- No, please, guys, guys.
If there's one thing
we're gonna do today,
we are playing that DVD.
Come on.
- Come on, man.
- Oh, yeah.
Oh, yes.
Oh, God.
Please, man.
Did you produce this track?
No, no, sit down.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
- Yo.
- [laughter]
- Got on the mom jeans.
- Whoo!
Look at the sweater.
♪ I'm the M to the C
to the m-o-m ♪
♪ And when it comes
to mom rappers ♪
♪ I'm the biggity best of them ♪
- Wow.
- She--is she rapping?
♪ I'm sending out this rhyme
to my homie number one ♪
♪ His name's Carl Stewart,
but to me he's just son ♪
Word up.
- Whoa!
- Oh, my God.
Okay, she got
that running man down.
- Look at Mom.
- Can we please turn this off?
- Oh, no, no.
- He said turn it up.
- Turn it up.
Turn up.
♪ You left some stuff behind ♪
♪ That I can send you
if you need ♪
♪ Like your best friend bear
and your magazines ♪
♪ I'm going
through all this stuff ♪
♪ But it looks pretty risky ♪
♪ You use so much lotion,
but your socks sure are crispy ♪
[laughter]
Mom!
- Come on, Mom!
- Okay.
♪ I've been cleaning
with the broom and the vacuum ♪
♪ And found Victoria's Secret,
and she's hiding in your room ♪
♪ Every nook and cranny,
there are wads of tissue ♪
♪ I can't even open
this swimsuit issue ♪
[laughter]
Man, what--what is wrong
with you, bro?
I spilled a soda
on that magazine.
Right.
♪ I'm getting your sheets
so nice and clean ♪
♪ Like when you wet your bed
till you were 16 ♪
- Mom, what?
- ♪ I overreacted ♪
- Okay, okay.
- Sorry I spanked you.
♪ Look, another crispy sock,
no, thank you ♪
(all) Oh!
- Why!
- No.
- She sniffed.
That is wrong.
How many crispy socks
she gonna find, dog?
♪ Crispy socks here ♪
♪ Crispy socks there ♪
♪ Crispy socks
with some mystery hair ♪
We're gonna turn it off
right now.
Come on, you guys.
Come on.
We started it.
We gonna finish it.
[faster tempo]
Oh.
Oh, the beat changed up.
[clears throat]
♪ I got the kitchen
and the basement ♪
♪ And the living room ♪
♪ And since your dad
met that bitch ♪
♪ I got his office too ♪
♪ Got my juices going,
my rhymes flowing ♪
♪ My breath blowing,
showing no signs of slowing ♪
♪ I can feel my skills growing ♪
♪ Took a little practice
to crack this ♪
♪ These lyrical gymnastics ♪
♪ But now the fact is
queen bee ♪
♪ I'ma be throwing out
your fucking mattress ♪
♪ Hell yeah,
baddest bitch in the biz ♪
♪ Taking this show on the road ♪
♪ You can clean up
your own jizz, nigga ♪
Peace.
(all)
Oh!
- Man!
- Yo, yo, MC Mom...
(all)
Put the pussy on the chainwax!
Ah!